the Joe Rogan experience yeah jewelry a
lot of [ __ ] crazy Chloe you see
yourself in a flossy car no don't care
about cars really really really but you
don't really bother you you show me that
thing you were very proud of it no you
see no I like it I like it but I don't I
don't really give I'm not a car guy
what's your stuff indulgence what's your
stuff yeah what do you what do you go to
that cars like what would i don't think
i think i don't know not that indulgent
I was like financially I don't really
care about jewelry too much of a
necklace my grandmother gave me I don't
really care about stuff like that
um like watches yeah but I don't really
care I stopped wearing my Rolex I just
thought it's too flashy and I thought I
get robbed so I was like I'm [ __ ]
everything what is that what you doing
this is just a for my running husband
garments yeah is you're on stage in
front of [ __ ] twenty eight hundred
people and then you go hey let's go out
to a bar after this and then you got
fifty thousand dollars on your wrist
yeah it's it's just kind of thousands
not what kind of Rolex you wearing
presidential rose gold dance you should
go straight Tracy Morgan just giant
[ __ ] gold ropes the fat gold ropes
and maybe a giant dollar bill sign I get
I get anxiety when I hear about you guys
spending money like or like we need like
something when you when you got this
place I got anxiety for you cuz I go
like I know you have a lot of money but
I go but are you afraid you're gonna run
out like that's how I am with money I
don't I'm a hard time spending it well
some people are famine thinkers yeah why
don't I buy I think yeah I think I do
and it's like when you got the the Lambo
I got scared for you because I was like
why would you do that yeah I'm trying to
get him to buy it for real yeah but you
like to spend money yeah you do like
spending money like spend enjoy it yeah
I grew up poor I like I like having
money I don't think you should have
money if you're not gonna spend it I
just don't I don't agree with that yeah
but there's not a part of your comic
brain that goes let's can all be taken
away yeah [ __ ] that
that's I got a different branding you
yeah
my brain doesn't work I work every
[ __ ] weekend because I go oh I I
wanna get the material sharp only get
ready for the special I want to make as
much money as well the Sun shines make
hay while the Sun shines
jeez you're gonna be fine to me more
often and stay off the Molly this guy
yeah is that the malayali all the time
yeah let's do it
so he doesn't feel bad to spend all his
money on bars and [ __ ] you know it's so
crazy that how what a character I've
become yeah but I'm not even a real
human anymore that's you know that was
Tennyson's problem he became a character
yeah kinnison even talked about it in
books Hunter has Thompson the same issue
you know as he got famous for being this
wild man you know and people that knew
hunter would say that when the cameras
were off he was a different guy but when
he knew that the cameras were there he
would all sudden take on this character
like you know there's a do you know that
um band beardyman mmm Fitzsimmons and I
were reading off Hunter as Thompson's
daily routine oh yeah yeah we're reading
it off and beardyman
turned it into a video turned on a song
and then turned into this crazy video oh
yes yeah okay it's really yeah I saw a
light up of this apparently didn't
really live like that every day it was
just like when someone whenever water
was there he was just like I'm just
gonna do coke and drink all day I'm
gonna wake up at 4:00 in the afternoon
and I'm gonna you know eat [ __ ]
Cheetos and Doritos and enchiladas and
be like this is my route drink
margaritas and you know 6:00 a.m. and
the hot tub went champagne you know and
that's that's what he would do and he
would ride in midnight after you mean so
we have this reporter there and he's
doing all these hard hard drugs up until
midnight and at midnight he started
writing well he writes till 6:00 a.m.
and then 6:00 and so cool it's not yes
you are I would like it that's cool that
guy like Kennison said they would just
lay out lines of coke for him like oh
it's him
you go through do you have no [ __ ]
idea yeah everybody's you I when I just
I don't bring I got bring a drink on
stage and I'll drink have my drink from
doing one show I'll have it when I tell
the Machine story but if I just have it
like a soda and I just take a big sip
they go [ __ ] nuts and and it's hard
because it's hard because I do like
drinking so like when people are like
hey can I buy you a drink you yeah like
alright and you're like whoa [ __ ] like
yeah yeah yeah right I get it and no one
had like when I told everyone I already
slipped me Molly on stage they just cure
you're the Machine and you're like I'm
also a [ __ ] dad like I'm crazy dad
but you I don't even know like I
remember hearing about Amy and Sara when
they got in trouble for the jokes they
made going up that's a character I do
and I can't wrap my head around a
difference between Who I am on stage if
I am up off stage like I'm the same
person so like I I can't understand
being a character even though you know -
yeah I know what you saying I can't
understand that either I'm bait I'm
basically the exaggerated version of me
on stage that is yeah yeah the finest
funniest ways I'm looking at life but
there are always I've actually looked at
life I've never said anything on stage
where I'm like this is about my
perspective but I'm gonna take on this
perspective in order to get these people
to laugh at me I hate that [ __ ]
I hate when comments do that I'm like
you don't believe that just change the
choked up yea orsa take take the high
road and try to write the [ __ ] joke
the way you want it to sound lasted
something's [ __ ] up to say that you
got to know that I don't really think
that I will say yeah you're saying I'll
say yes what I don't even [ __ ] think
that right I just think it's funny haha
know how much of you on the podcast is
who you are off it's like a hundred
percent of me on the podcast I've been
doing it for so long I don't think I
would know how to fake being someone
else no but nobody's like but also it
wouldn't work like this one of the
reasons why this podcast works is
because it seems like a hang like you
guys know me this is me yeah you know
yeah this is it yeah yeah yeah dizzy if
you if that wasn't the case but it also
makes it so much easier to imagine if
that if you had a character that you
were doing on a podcast then you have to
keep that character up
like for me that's one of the reasons
why it's so easy to do the UFC and so
he's even to do stand-up it's like I'm
live all the time yeah I'm the the the
idea of someone watching you is easy
it's more right like when I do those UFC
broadcasts and you know if I'm doing a
pay-per-view millions of people watching
this it's [ __ ] hugely important thing
we don't even rehearse I don't even know
what they're gonna ask me yeah that's
really crazy no idea of no idea and
that's how I've always done it but I
know what's happening I know who the
fighters are I know what's going down
but but that's just because I'm a fan so
when John Anik turns to me and he's like
you know in this light heavyweight title
fight you know you know John Jones and
I'll just start going off I just started
talking about it but it's because of
this because I do this so often
[Applause]